[Music]
is America having an ELO very small
Civil War columnist Lor shria writes in
this week's magazine about a standoff
between the Texas National Guard and the
US Border Patrol illegal immigration is
causing more and more problems in the
Republic she writes to tell us about it
Lono joins me now R welcome to spectator
TV nice to talk to you again now Lor
it's almost a cliche these days to say
that America is divided but in your
column this week you literally look at a
state that is defying the federal
government and using Force to do it tell
us about what's going on in Texas well I
defined it as a tiny Civil War because
it it is really about a state refusing
to get with the program in relation to
the federal government
uh it's a point of
consternation with border states that
the federal government is not doing its
job in policing the southern border of
the United States and uh Governor Greg
Abbott in Texas has decided to take
matters into his own hands and in one
tiny Place uh they he has sent in the
Texas National Guard which despite the
sound of it
is a state militia uh to take over uh
Eagle Pass there's a there's a park in
Eagle Pass it's a little town of only
29,000 people um but one that regularly
uh receives something like on an average
of 12,000 migrants per day which is
astonishing so uh Abbott has sent his
militia in to take over this territory
and a little bit more
on on the sides uh to try to stop
illegal immigration in that particular
area um I doubt it's very effective I
think that they're not um very
successful in still in stopping people
from coming in and they have nothing to
do with these people but to turn them
over to the Border force that um that
they're keeping out so it may just add
an extra administrative level
it seems symbolic to me it's a gesture
of of rebellion um you know
Circa
1860 and and the federal government is
taking uh the governor or at least the
state uh to courts right I mean they're
fighting this out in the Judiciary but
it's not even the first time that Greg
Abbott has fought the federal government
in the courts oh no this is ongoing and
um Texas put up these floating buoys in
the Rio Grand to try to stop people from
swimming to the
American Bank of the river and
um and the and DC sued to have them
removed um because it's the border
between two countries and that is a
federal matter DC is also suing to cut
the concertina wire that Texas has put
on the banks of that River to prevent
people from landing and and crawling
into the United States
um what's especially weird about this
conflict is that you would think that
the federal government and the state of
Texas would be on the same side I mean
why why aren't both parties interested
in controlling the flow of illegal
immigration into the United States it's
it's struck structurally and politically
bizarre well for British viewers who
might be more thinking about European
migrant crisis and not know so much
about the US side um you've kind of
hinted at it already but just how severe
are we talking about when we talk about
this illegal migration
problem
well I hate to Boggle our viewers
minds but it's way worse than Europe
right the scale of it is astonishing
so um it's estimated that between 8 and
10 million illegal immigrants have
entered the United States uh since Biden
took office uh and that's not an
accident that's not just a
coincidence um and and you know that
that's a significant swelling of a of a
population of about 330 million people
um and that it's putting enorm enous
strain on not just border states but now
Northern cities uh like New York and
Chicago which simply don't have the
means of handling this many newcomers
without any resources uh it's costing a
fortune uh New York City in particular
is is in a quandry because uh not only
has it declared itself a sanctuary city
which means they don't enforce
immigration laws um it's another kind
tension between the feds uh and and uh
other local
authorities uh but it's also got a
so-called right to shelter um and that
means that they are legally obliged to
put up anybody who doesn't have a home
and they have been applying the right to
shelter to not only New Yorkers who
become homeless but also just anybody
who rocks up
uh I wish I'd known that when I was
scraping as a as a postgraduate student
um would have saved me a lot of money uh
I and I don't I don't understand how
this continues um because it
will uh there's no there's no end in
sight of this flow of people there are
now
68,000 people in the in the New York
shelter system they've completely run
out of
room um they've actually had to cut back
on the budgets of all the other major
departments in order to
finance uh what I understand is um of
what is it
$400 per night per household and by
household uh that includes single adults
a single adult will make up a household
uh uh I mean most normal Americans
couldn't couldn't afford that and it's
just
astonishing you know as much as I hate
to say this the only thing that is
credibly going to bring a stop to this
is the election of Donald
Trump gosh and liono I I know how much
it would pain you to say that it pains
me
fantastically why why do you think he
will succeed because looking at his
first presidency you know after reading
your piece I did have a look at how
successful he was but he actually he
failed to get illegal migration down
when he was president the first time
around ice actually deported um the in
2020 the fewest people ever deported
since 2003 when the agency was set up
isn't it just a pretty intractable
problem it's it's incredibly
intractable um and it comes down to
problems with the wall law and
outdated immigration statutes it's this
is the same in Europe right so the the
US has signed up to the same kind of uh
Asylum policy that Europe has been
pursuing and um it's ruinous and the
weird thing is that most of the people
who are being led in and uh are allowed
to apply for Asylum don't qualify
even under very loose definitions of of
a legitimate Asylum claim but in the
United States and this is not that
different from a lot of places in Europe
including Britain there's such a backlog
that uh if you've applied you may be
getting a court date five years from now
even 10 years from now which is going to
give these people assuming they show up
for the court date which is big question
um it's going to give them PE grounds
for remaining permanently because they
will have established you know uh
households probably had children uh who
were American citizens um you know
so while the admission is temporary we
know better it's not temporary but but
why would Trump be able to solve it
better I I think um he will at least uh
change the rhetoric and I I'm really I
have to apologize for my tense because I
should have
said he might because we don't know that
he's going to be elected president so um
but in in let's say he is elected he
will put up a lot of
Bluster and there's there's certainly
going to be a fear on on on the migrant
side that you know he he talks such a
hard line all these people don't know
the statistics right talk such a hard
line that you know it's important to get
in uh while Biden is still president in
fact that's one of the fears uh on on
the administrative front that uh the
more it looks as if Trump might get in
then there's going to be a big push for
the border and the irony of that is that
it's a kind of self F in Prophecy in
terms of the presidency because as I
note in the column this is one of the
determinants of who wins the election uh
there's a huge uh anger in the country
over the kind of images that are coming
up uh being coming from the border and
it's um and it is changing people's
votes it on on a widespread level I mean
it I'm not uh I'm not statis
statistically supported here but I read
a lot of comments and the number
of uh lifelong Democrats that I
encounter uh in the New York Times who
claim that because of this issue
alone uh they're going to vote
Republican um that number is is huge and
so I I I think I think that a an even
further surge could easily uh push
Trump over the
[Music]
one